i want to go back to what you're talking
about the digital bill of rights so john
robb
uh an amazing futurist special forces
guy invented rss
advised dod and joint chiefs this guy
knows what he's talking about and his
focus
is on a digital bill of rights because
he understands that we need to own our
data
that's the first thing that's
sovereignty own your own data our
five-year-old kids in elementary school
are selling unknowingly giving away
their data by participating
by participating in education systems
how i love this idea of a digital bill
of rights
how do we get there uh
just like collective bargaining i think
people need
to understand that they have all the
power that they until
social media companies abide by these
certain rules we're not going to be
using them and i think
it it is possible but the odds are
definitely against us it's a david
versus goliath
battle but just as just as you said we
should have power
of about what data is sold on us just
like what we decide to give
to them should be decided by us and not
a huge
terms of services that's 20 pages long
that you can't even read
you know so again impossible fight they
would censor the crap out of it they
would make sure it gets no traction
but i think i still think it's it's
worth fighting because you never know
when
when david's gonna have that lucky shot
and uh
knock down goliath i think the bigger
problem is that
the left is fervent riotous angry and
demanding and
those that are not aligned with the cult
tend to be
i don't know cowardly no not not i i
say tend to be because there's obviously
people like you know us here
the people who watch the show who speak
up people like james o'keefe people like
jack who turned your you know his
cancelling into an
a uh an advantage but
who's who's gonna get off twitter like
who's gonna be like i quit
i harumph you know and then be like i
refuse until they fix these things well
the thing
is okay the big tech companies are kind
of also shooting themselves in the foot
as well by by blocking all the really
exciting people all the edgy people all
the wild people
all of them are gone off of all the big
social media platforms whether you like
them or not
uh they were pretty exciting they got a
lot of attention
a lot of them are gone so a lot of new
apps are coming in and this is why they
had to go as far as to
ban parlor of all things i mean that was
an extreme that was a big move
it was growing too fast it was a real
threat they told everyone make your own
social media company
people did and then what did they do in
response to that it was a major step
so so just like every fad things come
and go
i truly do believe twitter facebook
google i mean they're trying to cement
themselves as as
powers that be forever but i think their
time is limited because just like it
came
as fast and as quickly as it did it
could go as well
as fast as quickly it's asymmetrical war
and i think it's obvious
that you know uh
everybody knows a good guy's lost you
know you look at you look at censorship
getting worse it's not getting better
you look at joe biden placating china
it's getting worse not getting better
you look at the the demonization and the
vile
just disgusting things being said about
rush limbaugh it's just getting worse
it's not getting better
conservatives didn't do that to ruth
bader ginsburg i'm not trying to compare
the two like
the same thing but conservatives do not
do this
now there's an exception that some some
of these you know some people along with
the right do say awful things i've seen
it
and i called them out but as matt walsh
said it's the exception not the rule on
the left it's the rule not the exception
it's only getting worse uh anti-fuzz
still riding up in portland no one's
stopping them
just getting worse so i mean forgive me
if i'm not overly optimistic there are
some things i am
optimistic about michael malus believes
that were you know these conversations
and things like this show us
that we're on a path towards actual
victory and and maybe it's fair to say
that
getting worse means the night is always
dark as poor the dawn
and eventually they're going to implode
under the weight of their own
insanity and hypocrisy and then regular
people will finally say i've had enough
i wonder when that moment will be though
when people go to their windows
fling open the wind the shades and say
i'm mad as hell and i'm not going to
take it anymore
it takes a crisis it takes trauma it
takes a serious
personal trump traumatic experience in
order to break people free of ego
invested mental models
and narratives that they've adopted
right your mind is the battle space
right now your mind is the battlefield
if you don't actively occupy your mind
defend it and fill it with the ideas of
your choice they will be
it will be filled by other hostile
actors
we're all connected we all have
permeable barriers that might as well
not even exist
anybody can inject any old idea into
your brain that they want
and they're taking control of your
behavior through mind control
so it takes personal trauma
to cause people to even reflect
on whether or not their choice of
mindset
choice was healthy for them and then to
go through an experience with their ego
detached from this
this mindset that is a real phenomenon
that must take place that's why i really
do believe that there is a bigger agenda
whether it's the algorithm or the news
feed
to keep you in this negative thought
loop to keep you afraid to keep you
hating each other
to keep pushing this kind of race
beating divide and conquer agenda
and it's not just about race it's about
uh your sex your your identity your
gender your health
all these other ideas that they could
find that they could make you fight each
other or hate each other over
they're exploiting to the fullest extent
and as you mentioned jack
your your mind is like a muscle and you
get to choose whether you're going to be
optimistic and positive or pessimistic
and negative
and those choices are absolutely crucial
and when your perspective of the world
is controlled by a few tech oligarchs by
a few billionaires
it's in their best interest to make you
believe that all hope is lost
everything's very negative everything's
very bad and nothing
nothing ever good is going to come out
of anything
resistance is futile as they said in
those technology and culture will be
assimilated
exactly and and in reality they are
they are a lot more fragile than we even
know this supports my
theory of humility and why self trauma
is
imposing trauma on yourself is so
important by
humiliating yourself in front of people
is similar to working out
if you don't create muscular trauma by
working out
you will have trauma imposed on you from
the outside because you will become so
weak that you can't handle it
and it's the same way with your mind one
one way to expand on that is
if you don't when you and when you
exercise your arm right
you're damaging the proteins in the
muscle and then your body replaces it
makes it stronger makes it better
depending on what you're doing you're
getting muscle memory if you don't
develop that you become feeble out of
shape
the trauma could destroy you outright so
you need to harden yourself
to prepare for when somebody might come
and run full speed and punch in the gut
jordan peterson what we're talking about
that's what he says no that says take a
punch to the gut like houdini he totally
says exactly that well
what we're talking about here the secret
sauce and all this is intentionality
yeah are you going to be passive if you
are going to be passive you're dead
you're dead you're sick you're fat
you're chained to a desk
and you believe in an ideology that
wants you to commit suicide basically
isn't this the crazy thing though about
the great reset right so one of the
problems right now
with this great reset stuff is that all
the lockdown that we're the
the lockdown stuff we're seeing is
making people horribly out of shape
their like blood levels are getting
worse
they're sort of decaying in their own
homes but they're
if the idea is why i don't trust these
people and i think they're lying if the
idea was truly to
not own anything and be happy minimalism
actually i'm a fan of this
i love the idea that we find happiness
in just walking through the forest
and maybe just roll up your sleeves and
doing a good day's hard work
i'd love if that was you know the
movement and the idea
that behavior would make you stronger
instead they're calling it the great
reset but then locking in your house so
you can't get sunlight you can't get
proper exercise
and you wither away and become depressed
angry and feeble
yeah encourage you not to engage in
behavior that aligns you to the spirit
of the universe
the spirit of the universe is to create
is to build is to expand
if you can align yourself with the
energy of the universe you will find
yourself in alignment with
the universe i also find it devastating
that people are getting censored off
social media with varying opinions
because it's this traumatic
conversation when you have two opposing
views and the
the visceral tension that's created that
that strengthens
us against you know future conflict it's
like it's like we're
all in an mma match you know it's like
you're watching
you know conor mcgregor and he's
fighting mike tyson
and then facebook throws ebola a bolas
into the ring and
tangles up conor mcgregor's legs and he
falls down and mike tyson starts hitting
him and you're like
he didn't really win you know it was
facebook who threw the
what was it called the bola those two
bolo bola oh i thought
you were talking about the rope it's
like two two like
weights on a rope and then it wraps up
ancient weapon yeah i'm i'm actually
trying to make it as silly as possible
but no it's legit like these two ideas
have entered the ring and they're
fighting for the championship
right and then someone's literally
throwing weights at you know to [ __ ]
one side so the ideas don't win
if your ideas need uh someone to
basically cheat for you
they must not be good ideas yeah or
prevent the fight
entirely which is even probably even
worse than well yeah it's like they they
take they take
gregor out right and then before he can
even go in the ring they're raising mike
tyson's you know he's he's one
i i know they don't fight in the same
discipline that's pointless to continue
the hippie
the hippy dippy stuff that jack was just
get out about
because you are talking about a lot of
hippies
i may see it a little bit differently
but i agree on the baseline of it your
intentions
i don't think that needs more of a
conversation here because your
intentions absolutely matter
and we're living in a society that's
quick hit dopamine hits
get whatever you can get the likes get
and people don't really think about the
long-term
intentions what do you intend to be what
do you intend
to do people don't set goals people
don't set directives
people are not even in a mindset to take
a step back and realize
who do i want to be who do i want to
represent they're caught in this cycle
that the special elites want you to be
in and then you're stuck being someone
that you never even intended to be to
from the very beginning
things like meditation things like
gratitude to taking some time off
even just to sit back hey hey hey i
called you out on it first
uh i i you know taken some time to even
just
breathe deeply and and not to think and
let things
come to you no one does that and i think
the more we could do that
we'd be better off we would be i mean i
do it i do it every time i go on the
show
and it's incredibly important for me and
my mental health to be able to literally
take 10 minutes at least 10 minutes do a
guided meditation
on focus on peace of mind on clarity
and it really really really is key so
what are your intentions and your goals
what helps me a lot i think with
starting my business and getting my work
was playing
rpg video games when i was a kid me too
because
you start you're level you have this is
more like nerd i guess
you have no idols you have no weapons
and then you're given the wooden sword
you know
you have three hearts and a wooden sword
well you've got to earn the next heart
the game is difficult you can win
some of these games what game was i
playing i was playing uh um
uh immortals what is that game phoenix
rising it's a new game it's a ps4 ps5
awesome game and i'm i was i really
enjoyed it because
you can kind of just go where you want
to go and whether you actually level
your your character up and get them
the abilities they need if you have the
skill you can actually defeat some
pretty
serious bosses and it was like i i was
fighting one boss and i'm like why don't
i just go level up this is like taking
forever but it was fun right
i grew up playing these video games and
so my approach often when
in doing anything was always am i like
what's the level up
what am i acquiring what i have and what
am i going to gain
when you play these video games you
don't just start and then be like okay i
want to be level 100 with the best items
in the game it just doesn't happen you
can't do it
you start you get the wooden sword in
three hearts you want to get the level
up sword you gotta get the five hearts
first this is and you know nes engine of
zelda
you have to go through it the other
thing that helped me was skateboarding
because you can't cheat you can only
prove to yourself you've accomplished it
if you want to lie to others fine but
you don't get the dopamine you don't get
the
accomplishment so in everything i've
done i've not thought about
i want to be the ceo i thought about i'm
at level one what's level two
what's the next step i gotta do what's
the what's the you know the first step
in the journey of a thousand miles
what do i have to do it's pointless to
look at someone else and be like i want
what they have
well you don't know the path to get
there and even if you tried to replicate
everything they did you'd end up
somewhere else yeah they are the path
itself
we are the path we have taken it's not
the it's not the end it's the journey
i i think this conversation about
intention is amazing because i we were
talking about good and evil
and what what that actually is and i
think destruction isn't inherently evil
but if you intend
evil through destruction or creation
then there that's where evil comes from
is your intentions
and same with good well a lot of people
don't intend to do
to do bad and a lot of people are caught
up in systems and institutions that are
flawed and corrupted
and they're part of systems that they
don't see a way out of that they see it
as a norm to screw over the other person
to hurt the other person
it's their identity and they can't lose
sight of that because if they do they
would they would have an ego death they
can't
they can't even have that but again as
far as with the intention stuff you got
to ask yourself who do you want to be
what do you want to be represented by
what do you want your legacy to be and
these are questions no one asks
themselves
once a year i always take some time and
i always write out my goals for
a week a month a year five year
10 years down the line i want to make
sure that i'm on a path in my life and i
update it every year
where i'm going in a positive direction
always upgrading always doing something
that's that's keeping me focused on my
mission
and and having this kind of energy
within me
that that is happy and content with me
as a human being i think you're right
that people don't intend to do evil i
think that's not they never do it but i
think maybe a lack of
good intention disagree lack of
intention
the lack of intention is when evil will
seep in from these outside sources that
are creating your intention for you is
it is it evil
to uh uh dance on the grave
of people who die yeah is it evil to
power depends on why you're doing it
for for internet points oh for followers
and so all of these people on social
media
who are mocking the pain and suffering
of a family
who just lost someone to cancer is that
not
evil what good comes from doing views
doing things for views
for personal gain for for free that's a
good argument man there is
no good reason to dump on the grave of a
man who just lost
well if your family's starving and you
need money and it's the quickest way to
get the the food maybe you want to not
starve
you want to know who i i think had the
best tweet from
about any of it was marianne williamson
when it came to rush limbaugh
she said right now rush limbaugh is
standing before god listening intently
something like that and i said that was
an incredible that was that was an
amazing tweet
it was critical but it was respectful it
was calm it was reasoned and let's be
real she said he's in heaven
it was very nice of her she doesn't have
to like the guy i understand a lot of
people really despise the guy
but what she said i thought was a nice
way of saying look i'm critical of the
guy but
you know here's a calm rational approach
intentionality is everything it's a
superpower right now and i don't mean
your intentions
in the sense of like oh i intended to do
that but intentionality like
mindfully choosing your actions your
behaviors connecting to your values and
being strong enough to embody them
and to live them out in your life today
the system that we live in with social
media has hijacked your brain chemistry
and
encouraged you down negative behaviors
right
trolling people flame wars yada yada we
all know
what if there was a way to get a similar
dopamine hit
off of your electronics and
communications but it resulted in
positive energy
it resulted in building things creating
things instructing people and providing
and protecting other people
what if there was a network i'm sorry i
gotta do it guys
what if there's what if there's but the
reason why i'm what network no but
the reason why i'm bringing it up
honestly is because we just had this
conversation inside the liminal order
the other day
we have transferred all this energy that
guys were using on social media to do
things that were relatively unproductive
and possibly negative
and now they're getting the reward from
this engagement but with people that are
self-reinforcing this positive energy
they're building things together they're
exploring things together they're
teaching each other things
and they're doing the same actions that
they were on social media putting out
messages connecting with people
but instead of getting a negative
reinforced with dopamine
it's positively reinforced with dopamine
now and it's a cycle it's a beautiful
thing that we're seeing liminal order
you know nothing else sorry you know
it's awesome i i you know i really
despise twitter
it is a group of people that uh mostly
on the left but some on the right do
this
it's it's the exception on the right
it's the rule on the left
they formed communities of being awful
to other people and i think about
growing up skateboarding
and i tell this a lot because really if
you if go skate man go to a skate park
if you go to a skate park you've never
skated before there will be
101 90 100 of people there maybe 99
will absolutely love to teach you
everything they know about skateboarding
the rules the culture
the learning about skateboarding uh uh
trick names
and history it's oral tradition there is
no book that teaches you the language of
the skateboarding jargon
like if i said nollie hard flip back
crook big spin out
people i have no idea this but
skateboarders immediately are like oh i
know exactly what that is
you know a big flip back tail big spin
right these are things you learn from
people
you see it happen they tell it to you
there's no book go to a skate park and
you'll see
i've seen this before a 40 year old guy
who's never skated before who's
trying to learn how to do a kickflip and
he looks awful doing it
and then he finally lands the the worst
kickflip ever done and everyone in the
park is cheering and clapping and
high-fiving him
and they're like yeah because he
accomplished it for himself you're
surrounded by these people
who are cheering you on with a smile on
their face for your accomplishment
you're not better than anyone else
everybody knows everyone's got their own
thing
some people are really good some people
are arrogant i look at that community i
grew up in
of positivity of fun freedom recreation
and i compare it to what twitter is
they're mirror images they're opposite
of each other you know what
one a great lesson i learned growing up
was i studied acting for like 20 years i
went to school for it and a big part of
the
lessons was learning intention what do
you intend when you're on stage it's not
what you're saying what's my motivation
what's my motivation what do i want
from this situation and you your actions
and your words lead you towards that
and the goal was to make the other
actors look
better the idea a great actor makes the
other actors look even better
and that's the point and that's kind of
how i try to live oh well you're talking
about the servant leadership model in
that regard then if you're
the best kind of leadership is the one
where you look around at the people on
your team and you try to figure out how
to make their lives better
easier and the mission more easily
accomplished
servant leader i wish we saw more of
that in our president in the last four
years
just thinking back though about what you
said about the the skate community
that that really actually kind of
touched me a little bit that's that's
amazing right
just positive energy even for people
making the smallest
amount of progress right that's the kind
of environment you need to find
yourselves in guys if you go to the gym
and you're a total noob and you're fat
and you're out of shape
but you go in there and you break a
sweat and you put in the time i
guarantee you
every one of those guys that's ripped
and looks like he's on steroids and
everything else
is going to look at you and be like good
on you dude
good on you as long as you're there
doing the work
just getting better it's a hugely
supportive environment i'd be willing to
bet if you were fat and out of shape and
walked into a gym
and just saw some dude working out who
was like in shape and said bro
teach me he'd be like let's do it dude
absolutely here's here's what i do
here's what i like to do here's what
works for me
people love to share what what they do
they love to to to socialize
well especially when what you're doing
brings you joy and
health and longevity and peace of mind
and low stress and all these wonderful
things
yeah you want to share yeah you want to
share it man but that's why they shut
down gyms that's why they shut down
skate parks this is the craziest thing
i see i see all this on instagram
there's a lot of skateparks are still
open but it's crazy to me when i see
people are like
they shut down the skatepark for no
reason it's outdoor it's like
most there'll be 15 people there at a
time it's not there's not hundreds of
people
but they shut down why maybe because
people are gathering talking forming
communities
getting along do you think is that
insidious like the great reset
trying to destroy people or is it more
just they think people are breathing
heavy
transmit i think all of it is
intention in my opinion is is irrelevant
what i mean to say is
these are things that allow us to do
these things and whether it's on purpose
or not they've destroyed
these positive elements of our of our
communities they've destroyed our
communities
but you know for the most part people
are still finding a way to go out do
their thing and
you know it's not it's not absolute it's
it's it's crippled to a serious degree
but
at least people are still you know
finding ways to to have that community
i think man go to an open mic night you
know play some music if you're
fun or uh if you're learning and just
introduce yourself to some people and
say
hey it was a really great song you know
i'm here and they're like oh yeah we
come here every thursday and
just make friends and then everybody
cheers each other on but i tell you man
what you're talking about tim it's
community exactly
community community has proven to make
you happier healthier and wealthier
family that's another big element i love
this i love this idea there's a there's
a lot
you see these videos a lot where like a
mom will bring her seven-year-old kid to
a skate park
and then she's like i was really worried
they would the kids there would be upset
that my son was there trying to learn
and then it's like this touching video
where like one of the 17 year olds is
like let me teach your son some tricks
and then she's like i couldn't believe
how nice they were and welcoming and i'm
like dude
happens every single time at every skate
park if you come in with your kids
and you let your kids romp about and run
rampant and
don't communicate with people they'll
get mad at you
if you go in there and say we'd like to
you know help our kids learn
everyone's going to be like yeah dude
hey little man let me show you this
trick and be really
excited for you it's all about just
being a part of it you know it all
starts with
is it cool like is it cool if
you're like hey i know i'm not trying to
like get in on anything and ruin it or
whatever but can we try a little bit
you know a little bit of humility
combined with community
goes a long way it's what we're missing
today man yeah definitely
it's it's getting all i'm hitting my
eyes
but look at what twitter is it's the
opposite because it's all text
it's like you guys haven't seen the
episode right you guys you are watching
more do you guys want drinking more
occasionally the episode where rick and
morty get their toxic selves stripped
away from them yeah
yeah that's i think that toxic world is
twitter where they're just
oh i'm so angry i swear it's text
because if you're in video chats with
people it doesn't
it doesn't usually happen when you're
face to face with people it doesn't
happen as you were just saying i
literally just took the words out
when you see how big and tall i am it
usually yeah
but you've been you've been sniffing a
lot of lavender i've been saying
i have a quote that i think is
appropriate for this that i think jack
will be gushing over
uh uncontrollably it's one of my
favorite quotes it's a hippie
it's a hippie dippy quote and it says
watch your thoughts they lead to
attitudes
watch your attitudes they lead to words
watch your words they lead to actions
watch your actions they lead to habits
watch your habits they form your
character watch your character
it determines your destiny you know i
find with with intention career vibe is
your tribe
there's a tendency to want to like keep
repeating the thought and keep thinking
i'm great i'm great i'm great i'm happy
i'm happy
all you got to do is think at once and
then have no thoughts
and just let it resonate and that and
just have
faith in the process that one once you
create it once and just have no but you
have to have no thought
if you if you start to have negative
thoughts that will take the the process
and that you just allow with an empty
mind it to i don't know collaborate
yeah happiness is an inside job is what
i like to say all right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you